let's get into it our first question
comes from stephanie what is your
question
so my question is i went on a date with
the guy and he brought his dog with him
but he didn't bring any food or water
for the dog
so is that like a red flag that
he didn't bring something to take care
of his animal what kind of dog
like a little doberman like a small
little cute guy like a mini pin yeah i
guess that i mean a small dog is like an
accessory but if it was a great dane
that's a throuple right yeah yeah right
yeah also a straight man brought his dog
on a first girl
[Music]
if he had brought the dog and crushed it
like had been caring and nurturing and
shown like missed opportunity i think to
show that he's amazing with the dog
i would feel two things if a man showed
up with a dog on a date one i'd be like
oh my god so excited because the dog how
cute and then two no that's not gonna
work in the relationship and i'll tell
you why if that dog's get it getting in
the way at lunch
what's it going to do when you get home
you know what i'm saying right that
dog's in the bed now you talk about his
trouble hello so i think it's a red flag
okay all right thank you stephanie thank
you good luck
next up alton what is your question so
my question is uh so i went on a couple
of dates with a girl and after the
second date which was only about a
weekend she basically admitted that she
had really really strong feelings for me
and she was already ready to move on to
something more oh gosh
so i definitely liked the girl but i was
not ready to move so quick so my
question is how do i handle that without
hurting anyone's feelings
i always have the follow-ups how old is
she like 23. oh that's young
she was older tick-tock right if she was
older i'd be like you know what she
knows what she likes i appreciate the
emotional vulnerability
that's i say call witness protection
program
well yeah alton here's the deal yeah i
think
which if she's going this fast
girl she doesn't even know who you are
and so i feel like maybe she's creating
this fantasy version of you and
will the reality ever like live up to
her fantasy i think it's doomed for
disaster sorry
but
how do you say this is moving too fast
without throwing the baby out of the
bath water like how do you say
i'm still figuring myself out could we
take time to figure that out together
and and slow it down a little bit
without offending them or worst inviting
games in because you deserve that after
date two you you you're you deserve time
yeah
okay finally devin on twitter asked on a
first date is it a red flag if a guy
starts talking about how good he is at
his job and how much money he makes and
is he trying to boost his confidence or
impress me
huh
panel discussion
i guess it depends on the little kid
like if we're at an applebee's don't
boast about how much money you have over
an onion blossom
you know it's tacky it's tacky to talk
about money isn't it i mean you can do
it in subtle ways like i'll pay for
dinner or next time can i take you to my
favorite show at least let them know
that i have the money to support you
should this go farther but i to boast
about your money that's a huge red flag
i i think that was so well said mateo i
will take care of you i will whine and
dine you but i don't need to be gauche
and talk about my money at the table
yeah also what are you writing it down
and sliding it across like what is that
conversation yeah that'd be kind of hot
[Laughter]
that sounds like a 4am type thing
i think it's two different things right
i think the money thing does feel ghost
to me yeah but the i think we should all
say i think i'm good at my job yeah and
so talking about your job and what you
do feels like two different things i
think there's a way to flex and say this
is what i do that's what i'm passionate
about i think i'm really good at it the
money thing is where it gets
iffy for me yeah okay before we go we've
got another valentine's day check-in
with our couple in the audience
elizabeth and chris hello
and i heard you both are thrill seekers
where you would like to take each other
on an adventurous first date is this
true
yeah
we we both found out that uh we like to
do uh
dangerous thrill seeking things you know
we want to go skydiving yeah
i have to say i'm totally like you i'm a
thrill seeker so this is really fun i'm
so into this
well maybe when they jump from the plane
they'll fall in love
well this is the romantic moon fernway
edition makes beautifully hand poured
environmentally friendly soy wax candles
and the entire audience is gonna go home
with a hundred dollar gift card
thank you matteo lane and gloria
calderon kellett i so appreciate your
wisdoms and um your humor
and your thoughtfulness in having a
little uh drew and a uh valentine's day
edition thank you so much
[Music]
you